- We're trying to throw a dinner party
at a stranger's apartment.
Would you be down to come
to said dinner party?
- A whole bunch of random
people coming to one spot?
Are you kidding?
- [Sam] Would you invite
a stranger into your home?
What about a 100 random people
to your 200 square foot apartment?
I'm Sam, and today I'm in
New York doing just that.
Excuse me, do you wanna be friends?
- No, thank you.
- No?
Inviting a hundred strangers
to a stranger's tiny
New York City apartment.
Why here?
Well, it's a place known
for the kindness and warmth of its people.
Do you want to be friends?
No.
And it's very spacious
living arrangements.
We've done this twice before
at UCLA and a Trump rally
but now we've taken it to "The Big Apple"
to show that even if a
city looks unfriendly
and you don't have a lot of space
you can still bring new friends together.
(dramatic music)
Excuse me? Do you wanna be friends?
- No, not particularly.
- Do you want to be friends?
- No.
- With who?
- With me! I'm Sam.
- No.
- Excuse me. Do you wanna be friends?
- Sure.
- Would you be down to host
a dinner for strangers?
- I'm really not sure.
- Where are you heading?
- Wherever the wind takes me.
- We're about to go to
Grand Central Station.
Do you wanna come with us?
(orchestral music)
Who should we make friends with next?
- The woman in purple.
- [Sam] See that?
Okay, we're going.
We're going. Let's go.
(upbeat music)
Excuse me, do you wanna be friends?
- Yes.
- Do you wanna be friends?
Do you wanna be friends?
- Not today.
- Why?
Do you wanna be friends?
I saw you looking.
I saw you checking me out.
- I was checking out your trainers.
(Sam chuckles)
- Um Sure.
- I'm Sam.
Excuse me, do you wanna be friends?
- Yeah.
- Cool.
- I'm Courtney.
- Courtney.
What's it Courtney and?
- Danecy.
- I heard like a southern twang.
- Alabama.
- Alabama. Wow.
We're planning on throwing a dinner party
at 6:00 PM on Sunday.
Would you be down to host?
- No.
- Why not?
- I don't think so.
I don't want strangers in my house.
- Would you attend?
- I can't. I can't.
I'm at work.
See me any other time I would've done it.
- Tonight is our last night from here.
- We are gonna go
probably to NYU right now.
Do you guys wanna come with us?
- Um well.
- Yeah.
- We just might.
- Everyone introduce themselves.
- Courtney.
- Danecy.
- Jairo.
- Sam.
(Sam laughs)
Let's go.
(upbeat music)
- [Sam] As we were walking
to Washington Square Park
I couldn't stop talking to random people.
Hey, do you wanna be friends?
- Uh sure.
- [Sam] And so Courtney and
Danecy decided to ditch me
and maybe meet up later.
And I have a secret.
I have a secret.
Come over here, come over here.
Whoever agrees to host this
party, I will pay their rent.
Do you wanna be friends?
- No.
- Not even a little bit?
- Sure.
- Do you wanna be friends?
(cat purrs)
- What's your name?
- Sara.
I'm Sam.
Do you live in New York?
- No, this is my first time,
and I came with a specific purpose.
- What's the purpose?
- I wanted to
walk through the halls of NYU Law.
I'm applying but once
I've manifested that,
then I'll remember today.
- I'm gonna manifest on your behalf.
(Sam speaks gibberish)
Do you ever host people?
- Yeah.
- Have you ever hosted strangers?
- Would you host a dinner
party for strangers
on Sunday at 6:00 PM?
- Probably not.
- What if they're creepy?
- So would you come to a
dinner party for strangers
in a stranger's apartment.
- When is the dinner party?
- Sunday at 6:00 PM.
- Oh good. I am not
doing anything on Sunday.
- You wanna be friends?
(Joe drumming)
- Sure.
- What's your name?
- Joe.
- And what do you do for a living?
- Play drums.
- Would you consider hosting
a dinner for strangers?
At your apartment?
- Absolutely not.
- Why absolutely not?
- I don't even wanna host
a dinner for my friends.
Why the (bleep) would I wanna
host a dinner for random people?
(Sam laughs)
- All Right.
- I don't know.
You don't know what they have in their-
you know what I mean?
I'm not that-
I mean, I guess I'm fairly trusting,
but not that trusting, you know?
- Wait, is there any reason
that you haven't like,
aren't that trusting or?
- Um life is hard.
I started carrying a knife to school
when I was in sixth grade.
People would try to jump me.
I used to smoke weed in a
meth lab in eighth grade,
like before going to school. Yeah.
I mean, if I grew up in the suburbs
maybe my life would be all peachy.
- I think like, you know,
all kind of humans go through trauma.
Is there a way,
do you think you can like shed that or?
- LSDs and mushrooms.
- Facts bro.
(Sam chuckles)
You think it's also like
just connecting with random people too?
- Yeah. I mean I do that all day.
- So one more time.
Would you come to this
dinner for strangers?
- No
- Dude, nice to meet you.
Keep playing drums.
(drums playing)
Do you want to be friends?
- Do I have any friends?
- Do you wanna be friends?
- Oh yeah.
- With me?
I'm Sam.
- Daniel.
- Would you ever host a dinner party?
A classy dinner party for
strangers at your apartment?
(Sam laughs)
- These are new friends
also that we made today.
- Are we having like a
dinner party at my place
or like is that-
- Do you think?
Are you saying we can do that?
- I mean, yeah.
I mean-
- Yes?
- Yeah. What kind of dinner?
- I don't know.
We're gonna like try to put it together.
Could we have like a tour
of your apartment later?
- We can schedule.
Yeah, we can schedule.
- Can we schedule something?
Okay. Okay.
We got it baby!
- It is Jairo's now duty
to say, "Wanna be friends?" to a stranger.
- I'll try to get a
stranger to be a friend.
And maybe if they want to
go to his dinner party.
Excuse me.
Do you wanna be friends?
No? Okay.
Excuse me.
You wanna be friends?
- No, I'm good thanks.
- No? Okay.
Excuse me.
Do you wanna be friends?
Pardon? Do you wanna be friends?
- No.
- No? Okay.
Excuse me. Do you guys wanna be friends?
- I'm good.
- No?
Excuse me, ma'am. You wanna be friends?
- Sure. What's up?
- If someone were to invite
you to a stranger's house
to have a dinner party would you attend?
- Oh I have plan this Sunday.
- Dang.
There we go.
- I'm trying man.
(upbeat music)
- Hey guys, quick question.
You guys wanna be friends?
Do you wanna be friends?
Wanna be friends?
- Uh yeah sure.
- Why?
- Because you're wearing
blue and I'm wearing yellow.
Like primary colors.
- Yeah I like that because-
- Yeah, I'm Sam.
What's your name?
- Thomas.
- What's your name?
- Tori.
We're trying to throw
a dinner for strangers
in a stranger's apartment.
- Okay.
- Would you come
- 6:00 PM on Sunday?
Yes?
- Yes?
- Yeah, sure.
- Actually?
- I think so.
- Okay cool.
- What is the weirdest
thing that's happened
to you in New York?
- Uh, went viral like in the
beginning of the pandemic like-
- Why?
- My neighbor sent a drone to my apartment
cause I was dancing on the roof
and we went on like dates
and everyone was following it.
- Yoooo.
I didn't know I was
talking to a celebrity.
Wait, so how did the dates go?
- They went well.
I mean, we're not dating, but like-
(everybody laughs)
- Bye!
(comforting music)
- Hello.
- Hi.
- Do you wanna be friends?
Do you wanna be friends?
- Sure
- Sure. Why not?
- Sure.
- Do you wanna be friends?
- No.
- What's your name?
- Luke.
- Luke. I have a question for you.
We're trying to throw a dinner party
at a stranger's apartment.
Would you be down to come
to said dinner party?
- No, I wouldn't
and I'll tell you why.
- Yeah, tell me why.
- Because somebody's
gonna take advantage of it
and they're gonna say,
"Oh, I'm gonna be the stranger.
They think they're gonna have a good time.
I'm gonna pull up and sabotage it"
and they're gonna do some crazy (bleep)
And next thing you know,
you guys are gonna be in New York Times.
- So you think we're gonna get sabotaged?
- Yeah.
- For sure?
- Yes and then I want
you to play this footage
when it happens.
You guys are getting (bleep) over.
It's happening.
You heard it from here.
- Dude, now like,
I'm like kind of wondering like,
should we even be doing this?
Like, is this the right city?
Luke shook my confidence for sure.
But I reminded myself how far we had come.
We made dozens of new friends
and secured an apartment
from our main man, Daniel.
So as long as we keep up with this pace
we might be able to pull this off.
(phone ringing)
- [Daniel] Hey, what's up?
- Daniel. My main man.
Your roommate.
What exactly is she like worried about?
- [Daniel] Like the safety
and just the purpose, I guess?
- Yeah.
- [Daniel's Roommate] As a woman.
- Yes.
- [Daniel's Roommate] That
is so incredibly unsafe.
And in fact, I would never
recommend anyone do that
as a woman ever in their lives.
I know very many people, myself included,
who have gotten themselves into
situations that are unsafe.
- Yeah.
- [Daniel's Roommate]
Because by trusting people
that maybe they shouldn't trust.
That makes me very uncomfortable.
So that's just my personal take on it.
- No, I understand and I also
understand it's a big ask.
- [Daniel] Good luck finding
someone else to host.
- Will do. Will do.
Later.
Okay, so I understand why
Daniel's roommate is
repulsed by this idea.
When creating a community of strangers,
safety is something that
doesn't feel guaranteed.
That feeling can be a
barrier preventing community.
But I think my goal with this video
is to show that the default is good.
That the average stranger on
the street can be a new friend.
But maybe I'm wrong, maybe
I can't pull this off.
Excuse me, juggling man.
Do you wanna be friends?
Excuse me. Do you guys wanna be friends?
- Sure
- Sure.
- [Stranger] It's his birthday.
- It's my birthday.
- Dude, Happy freaking Birthday.
How old are you turning?
- 17.
- What does it feel like to be 17?
- I'm old.
- I'm here trying to throw
a dinner for strangers
in a stranger's apartment.
Would you host that party?
- I don't have enough
room for a 100 people.
- Would you attend such a party?
- Tomorrow?
- Yeah.
- Sure.
- Actually?
- Excuse me, do you guys wanna be friends?
- Yes.
- Sure.
- Yeah.
- I'm Sam.
- Will, nice to meet you.
- What do you do for a living?
- I'm a lawyer.
- A lawyer?
- I am trying to throw a
dinner party for strangers.
- Okay.
- In a stranger's apartment.
Would you be down to host a dinner party?
A classy dinner party for strangers.
- Bro, I'm sorry, I'm
gonna have to say no.
Can I say a quick prayer for you?
- Yeah, I would love to.
- Lord, I thank you for Sam's faith
and Lord, I just pray
that you would establish
his plans right here, Lord.
And help him to find the
perfect place in Jesus' name.
Amen.
- Amen.
- Yeah man.
- You know what man?
- It aligns.
I know it's weird, dude.
But it's like what we're trying to do is
and I think that's the same thing
that you're trying to do too,
is just like show that
there's like empathy
and love in this world
and we would bring everything.
- Okay, well now I mean, it-
I don't know
- Do you feel like it
fits with the mission
that you're trying to do?
- Maybe it would, I don't know.
- I think-
- Here, how about this?
Why don't you grab my number
and we can talk a little
bit more about it.
- Yeah.
- What if we brought some dinner over
to your place tonight
and we just talk about it?
- Okay.
- Yeah?
- Sure.
- Will said he'd think
about hosting this party.
So at the end of day two
this challenge is
completely up in the air.
I'm hoping that through the
power of a good conversation
and great New York City pho,
we'll sway his decision in our favor.
But we'll see.
Hey Will.
Hey, nice to see you.
Hello, Hello.
- All right, dude.
- The grand tour.
Yeah. How many square
feet do you think it is?
- Probably like 250?
- 250?
- If that.
- So what made you wanna study law?
- I mean, I used to be like
a really big troublemaker
when I was younger.
- Really?
- And like drinking, doing drugs.
By the time I was in college,
I was like a full blown, like drug addict.
- What was the moment that like
you decided,
like how did you-
cause it's like,
what changed I guess?
- I think I was just so tired
of like going through all that.
Like why don't I just
try the sobriety thing?
Because it couldn't
possibly get any worse.
I applied to like 20 law schools.
I only got into one.
I loved it.
It worked out great.
I got the exact job I wanted.
- And what is it?
- I'm a public defender.
- Wow.
- [Sam] Are you down to host this party?
- Like, why not?
- [Sam] Yeah.
Why did you agree to
host this dinner party?
- When you said the thing about like,
people being closed off.
I kind of felt convicted.
Why am I-
like why is my default, "No"?
- We'll get out of your hair
but we'll see you tomorrow.
- Okay.
- [Sam] Will agree to host this party
but Daniel did too
and that fell through.
So I have no idea if this
apartment will hold up.
But I'm cautiously optimistic.
Now we just need people to show up
which might be more
difficult than I thought
because people are starting
to drop like flies.
So we went back yet again
to the friendliest place in New York City,
Washington Square Park.
I think we need a sign.
Hey, you guys wanna come
to a dinner party tonight?
You wanna be friends?
No.
All Right.
Do you wanna be friends?
Sir, with the plants.
Man with plants.
Do you wanna be friends?
This is like the third
time you've looked over.
You gotta come say hi.
Do you wanna be friends?
- [Fireman] Yeah. Why not?
- Actually?
- [Fireman] Yeah, sure.
- We're trying to throw
a party for strangers.
Would you guys wanna come?
- Maybe?
- I'll go.
- [Sam] Actually?
- Yeah.
- Come over here.
What's your name?
- My name's Angelique.
- Angelique. Sam.
Nice to meet you.
Can you tell me a little
bit about yourself?
- All Right.
I play lead guitar in a band.
- Wait, can you bring your guitar?
- I don't have it with me.
Actually, one of my friends does.
- Do you want to come help
make friends with me right now?
- Oh my god.
What?
Um okay, yeah sure.
- All right.
- Let's go.
(upbeat music)
- You wanna be friends?
You wanna be friends?
Excuse me sir, do you wanna be friends?
Do you wanna be friends?
(trumpet playing)
- No thank you.
- That's okay.
- Sure, why not?
- Do you wanna come?
- Okay. Yeah.
- [Sam] Yeah.
- No, we gotta do things.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. I'll probably come, definitely.
- Oh wait, this is Sophia.
Okay, you're on the camera.
Will you be coming to the dinner party?
- Yes, I will be there.
- Tonight? No, I'm just gonna
be out with some friends.
- Sick. Well if you want to
invite some friends here.
You can.
- What's going on guys?
Today we're in someone else's vlog.
- [Sam] Ooh. Vlog in a vlog.
- We're going to a stranger's
dinner party tonight.
- Oh so he is going.
He is going.
- He's coming.
(upbeat music)
- Will, what do you think of
like doing a poetry party?
- [Will] I'm so down
bro, I like that idea.
- All Right. See you soon. Peace.
- Hey, hey. How's it going?
- [Will] Good man.
- Nice to see you.
- Good to see you bro, good to see you.
- This I think will be the stage.
- Right, right, right.
- [Cameraman] Hello!
- Hello.
- What's up!
- Our first guests.
- This is awesome.
- What are your names, by the way?
- [Sophia] Sophia.
- [Angelique] Oh, I'm Angelique.
- And?
- Angelique.
- And Angelique.
I'm Will, nice to meet you guys.
- [Sam] It's 5:19 and everyone's
supposed to come at 6:00.
So we've just kind of set up the place.
Why do spontaneous things at all?
- We're only here on this earth
for a certain amount of time.
Like you might as well
make every day exciting.
Like every time the sun rises
is a new opportunity for you to like
do whatever you want.
And I think that that's super awesome.
And I think that life
is the most fulfilling
when you really take advantage
of everything that you can.
- [Sam] So we're out of time.
I mean, we spent the last three days
asking a bunch of strangers
to come to this random tiny
apartment in New York City.
And now all we can do is wait.
(clock ticking)
(footfalls)
(door opening)
- [Sam] What's up?
(footsteps)
- Hello dude.
Nice to see you again.
Come on in.
Tori! It's nice seeing you.
This is Will.
- I'm Will, nice to meet you Tori.
- Dude, come on in here.
Dude, nice to see you.
- Katie, hello!
I guess, I was not expecting
all these people to be here.
- [Cameraman] Here's our star.
- The amount of times I've
walked past this place.
- Hello Jairo.
- Hello.
- This is a stranger's apartment.
I met him yesterday.
His name is Will.
I'm in New York City
and I made 100 new friends!
(everybody cheering)
Thank you all for coming here.
All of you are,
were strangers to me,
before I came to New York.
And now you are all in
a stranger's apartment.
Will, who so graciously
has hosted this party.
So give it up for Will.
As a token of gratitude for hosting
we wanted to help pay rent.
So here is some money
for helping us do that.
And here you go.
(everybody cheers)
I'm really happy you're all here.
So you guys all have poems,
so we're gonna read some poems.
And also,
I also want to shout out Heelys
for sponsoring this event.
(everybody cheers)
I'm so grateful that
everyone came to this party
and a super big shout out to Heelys
for helping sponsor the event.
In fact, Heelys was kind enough
to send some of our party guests,
their own pair of Heelys.
- I love Heelys.
- Whether it's in a
class or on the street,
meeting new friends can be pretty neat.
- But through this incredibly hectic mess,
the random people you meet,
when you just say, "Yes",
it's what makes this city it's best.
(everybody cheers)
(soothing music)
- [Sam] I really appreciate you
taking the chance.
- Dude, I'm glad I did it.
- Thanks for saying yes.
We thought that no one was
gonna show up, earlier today.
We were really worried.
People were dropping out
and like, look at all
these people behind us.
All right, is everyone ready?
(photo clicks)